sometimes there are moments where you
think well why am I doing this it seems
that I will never be perfect it's
impossible to become perfect perfect
chess players and it's impossible to
make only perfect chess moves there are
always moments when you lose a game and
you're not able to do anything and in
this moment I ask myself why am I doing
this
you
my name is Alexandra Costa nuke I came
from Russia Moscow I'm a chess player
professional chess player I started to
play chess at the age of five
my father taught me how to play chess so
I was watching my father playing chess
with his friends and then my I got
interest to play chess and my parents
were a little bit afraid because I was
too too little but when I became four
and a half then even before then they
decided that it was probably time to to
show me the rules and I must say that at
that moment I realized all the rules
myself and but still it was important
that my father just repeated this lesson
how rules are in chess I'm 21 and I
started to play chess when I was five
and my father was teaching me since he
was an active player in the 1980s 90s
and then when I was five and my brother
was and then at this time of seven years
one he was just taking us to tournaments
and he told us chess and he gave up his
Kira she's fast
you know mokemo Marcus Oh No Yellin desi
sunidhi Doble no not okra shoot Olie
patty Mentos Coppertone Mondelez cocky
Connor vas a satanic a rune inglaterra
miss Rowley music East a concert ista
the pianoforte euro legalese fetch FSM
pre-comp or see arrow completamente
a Novato Posca part okay Chum questo
yoko maravillosa case k modest cocky voy
con los capetto k chones cocky AIRAID OV
amo factor cattivo patanti joni mitchell
mio padre tsunami in san e or low sempre
con en scène yato Camilo Calgary I'm
Casey Benoni Okawa he treats upon libro
de que let o me fat Oh le probe a condo
their mo politically bro some Da Vinci
Code Eliska cake windy my father he
taught me when I was 13 and after I got
a coach from for my color and I start
playing many tournaments welcome in
Chateau Jacare i do D Johnny salad I got
a boy you're simply supported here
because he's a big one McArthur lost if
I know Padre my company Otto Antonelli
Scott okay rookie second over here
officer Juan Cacho
so kneebar to go with a jockey
inoperable Spinelli Scott no punches
asakari value so I from from the
beginning I didn't like to lose and even
even I was crying for several times and
then my father said that if I I would
cry once more than he he will stop to
play with me and so this was a big
threat and then I decided that I should
keep my nurse and I should play his out
crying
really Jankovic cave I meant a party
little la cuenta today or instead lick
impress o Colunga altro sporty Uffizi ko
ko ko' ko no follow pooja little coral
on car chopin or a su aniversario coco
cisu chair Elsa Christopher Dada say
propio a Punto disentitlement agar ego
Peleliu Horton problema en estas
Parramatta Sade suna pas de quoi vez en
estas ceremony tranquil a concentrate a
spa Guevara meant a solo dentro de
bastante West it's really getting on
your nerves it's awareness it's taking a
lot of few nerves and still you have to
be very clear if to keep some
concentration
it's really a like it's a hot game in
some way because you have to be
concentrated all the time and it takes a
lot of the energy you realize it's all
usually always at the end of the
tournament you're very tired something
to get any sake and stuff when they come
home very pale on the face and just
feeling weak and out of energy that's
why a lot of chester has tried to do
some exercises you know to like I don't
know Ron or being a good physical shape
because it's very important you know
because otherwise it's very hard chess
is very stressful that's why a lot of
people quit you know because after many
years you know the nerves are not so
good anymore because it's a lot of
stress I think there are other sports
are not as stressful because when you
are playing for so long for yourself you
know it's very hard and when you play
soccer or tennis you know you're moving
a lot you know so it's healthy but when
you play chess it's not so healthy you
sit like this you know for many hours
it's very hard no party tells oh no per
my particular ascent ok so NASA Kranti
magari all three ragueneau molto
I pay Ariano Sado season k party take a
no sono positon penalty de quoi no no NC
troppo de calcul are dependent ada
quanto Kenosha la posición que esté
Giocondo son party Takeda mint AC
lesotho Purdue or a concentrate ISA no
PI tacky not emo to the so Tony ask
Akira the Corsica Clemente a lieutenant
Sione we should garage on our area
seguirá for chess players physical
conditions are extremely important
because if you have any if you have any
problems with nerves or physically you
are not feeling well then you simply
cannot keep concentration for hours and
the chess game is when you play this
equal open enter on the top level and
chess game can continue till six seven
seven hours and it seems to be long but
each minute I can say each second but
sometimes even each second can be
decisive so you must keep concentration
during all this time and if you have
problems is a health simply you can so
you cannot achieve success in chess
this car Katie insane you know la
responsibility' keone massa a la sua HMO
jelly factor a causal patty common take
a condo fire hose on dose patty patty
comment a a two-party culpa - ah - PO
Miller are a joke Oh dope Oh Emperor
type a nice udita Queenie
- pardon party taper diverse emo TV
pro/con SI un giorno moto moto uo
vanadium produções selección anal Vitas
even chassis Paul de Chivo liudmila
quando Vinci anche EDT Amadeus a Felicia
cuando cuando Pardee quest Edna vibra
chase kichan problema complacency super
utility denali see Erin poem essays on
steve-o complement Rannells exactamente
una economía Nell economía - I poo suite
editor a multi-component a pero no se my
situation pachinko Omega sensitive Arlo
soos exactly
so much equally complex this cation
historian from place yeah suppose the
capacitor recently develops their minds
their logic their creativity and a lot
of new things and I believe the chest
there is a place for chess in the school
program and I think Josh should be
included school program my Emma Casa
fundamentally each amo la mia vita Kon
Protestantism that week on contrato Saku
de persona and capercaillie below do Co
okay Nonnie solo on sport proteome
piacere aesthetic o con este Giocondo
que una vez a annyong DISA Santa Paws un
Conde de la stessa Yoya
cuando una cosa que saprykin fini Delita
aquí de cultura de lingua chess has the
has its own language you know there's a
chest notation that you don't have to
speak English Russian Spanish or Italian
I mean the with this notation everybody
can understand each move because the
board has each square has a name so
that's that's wise you can see in
tournaments you can see in tournaments
two players analyzing a game and they
don't speak the same language but they
can understand you know the moves it's
just just a special language and so this
is like what like language which
everybody knows and let's say chess is
maybe like Esperanto and people who
knows who know how to play chess they
can communicate each other by internet
or in real life
you
[Music]
you
I was for half a year I was pupil of his
school and so between Nicole it was
saying that just just you can imagine
chess as a philosophical problem problem
and so if you are if you develop your
mind if you develop your philosophical
ideas then you can deeper understand
Belo Monte Carlo Mondale - totally -
coach Anker accompanied each a more
artistic insist okay - richer kaduk
appear commie pets invent coordinate fa
DeLauro pinyin chitose-kun - Val chancay
manera de Chama stetic opposition to a
calculator a masseur on tipo de silicon
esto estará been in questa positio no
male questo low puede Cocola voi capias
all tanto
position 10 loss in Tendo calico so pets
in Manila
post Emmanuel Monica so the pieces tell
me please free me when I when I have a
piece that's not developed or a piece is
out of the game it is I think it's very
unfair for that visual I tried to bring
it again it's they don't really speak
like this like I always try to help I
don't know somehow I think they mean
what they mean is intuition or pattern
recognition which happens for a lot of
people like you play your game
it happens with me actually all the time
you play your game but you feel inside
that you already played this you already
seen this before every move you need to
do some kind of choice and we can't say
that that the game of chess is a game of
how you make this choice because in this
you make choice if it's right you
sometimes win and if it's a bad choice
you you can lose so well you're just
first of all you try to understand what
which move is better try to calculate
some variations if you cannot you're not
able to calculate and to understand
which move it better you just you just
rely on your intuition because she with
I've been playing chess for many years
and intuition depends on your experience
sometimes you just make your move and
then it happens as this move is a very
good one and many ask why did you make
this move and say well I don't know it
it seemed for me that this move would be
better so just intuition experience of
course some kind of calculation reversal
a solo Allen RCRA
regardless to deallocate a rich fkv
Kosovo be equal into dota multi-sports
Arceus a creative in my head entre que
los Batista UNCC stay compositor Anu
stay sue demos mundo me
there was one funny story about a man
called Villa me rich from Yugoslavia and
this was told to me but it was lovely it
was just with the Americans start to go
Bua Slavia was the first round of the
u.s. love championship and so they are
they are sitting there in front of the
phone in front of the board about to
play and all of a sudden they hear
explosions in the background and
everybody is looking around what's
happening and film in which called the
arbiter I remember oh yeah it comes over
a minute Jesse what is the time control
and astronomy's absolutely
it wasn't paying any attention to his
city being bombed he just wanted to know
what how much time you had to play the
game so really if you have a
concentration you literally don't hear
the bombs as this example shows if
you're playing well if you are playing
badly then if you are not concentrated
then you are disturbed by somebody
drinking water two tables away and if
something disturbs you like this then
you know it's it's not a good day for
you so you have to get in this zone
where you don't hear you don't see you
don't smell nothing you just and it is a
type of meditation when it's it's good
you know you only have the pieces you
have the chessboard and you're a
commander whatever you do I mean you get
what you do and there is no place for
and you know just words you have actions
and you you are able to prove whatever
you want to prove so sempre no joke
odalisque rkj resolute she owned a ditch
a massive inches apart by perigee pero
la la vita tantos peso non chilies Lutze
Onan never in a report Yankee and now
I'm to deliver Oh in it CMO tanta cause
because if you the feature it's gone
mental vehicle on educational
philosopher moto sahaja pero yo siempre
pensado que cosa de feature
Eddie the deport Ariella fini una cosa
que tu ne T Otto Rocco joke odalisque
aki questa CJ dissembler only Giorno I'm
over partita a lot of people have said
and it's true that I believe that you
know chess is just small you know
example of life because you also leave
you know like in the game you know you
it's a long game you know you play like
life right you learn and you keep going
and you have to sometimes you have to
sacrifice something in order to get
something right you have to lose
something to achieve something and
sometimes it's better to you know
instead of going forward you know go
back sometimes and think you know to
make some strategy decide what you want
to do because there are a lot of plans
in chess you know it's not the only one
way to we know it's not like that you
know there are a lot of different ways
you can go when you play chess you know
and it's very important to make a right
choice like in life you know you have
many opportunities but you have to make
sure you make the right choice in order
to you know get what you want to go so
that's why I think chess and life are
very close to each other because you
know you chess if you make it wrong
choice to make a bad plan you lose your
game and the same in life you know you
lose the life and it's over you know
hope you like it's God but in chess you
know you come back cuz chess is a very
creative gaming you can just develop
your plans and in this game it's like
you know in real life you cannot always
do what we want to put on the chest sing
in the chest value can just make our own
lens of own decisions without being
responsible K when we make a mistake we
lose but in life sometimes to make this
risk has much much more consequences
like to to put money on some wrong
account and utterly you lose your money
it's much below it's much worse than to
to the chess game I think see a mold of
acidifier confuse I own a pair o throw a
tomato and Luke appeared in pirarucu my
kunai you - no no aplicación is kakoton
illusionary numenera
booty retro is in duncan Akasaka Stinson
under a given car a wound up to 200 tied
with modern equipments it's multi
because a mod equipping siddhis khaki
pencil agita no a complete artist goes
by christos khaki - aniversario
communica - phylla - apart a la otra
tanto de Pena low cost of a single altro
no minimus in my castle tests over sorry
mekka channey la vida
you
you
many years ago there was a difference
again before the Internet age and women
used to like in tennis we're in the 70s
women were doing moon balls backwards
and forwards you look at women playing
tennis now
it's this much above the net and they
play fantastic tennis now also women
play fantastic chess not so many and one
reason is just lack of interest one
difference is for sure that every woman
at the beginning I think my opinion just
when you're starting to be 20 and
getting older which is singing about
family and getting kids notice that for
men it's not the same men can fix on one
thing much much more easily more just
move not to emotionals we cannot just
fix on shasthri you have to do some
other things around I can't imagine that
anybody can just fix on one sings out
singing about other things it's not in
our nature just to fix on one thing
since we're women and we have some
family thing inside us I think it's just
a biological matter that's one reason
why men are just better than women and
shares because they can easily just fix
some shares without having anything
around that a woman is impossible the
other thing is just that men are much my
classes are going to have more much more
present than they're seeing in chess and
sometimes important to take some risk
and to be a much more vicious than to
has a success is it a passivity
a woman is it's because of the nation
also possible women don't like to
dedicate their whole time to chess you
know they like other things in life too
you know they don't want to spend so
many hours stunning as men so that's
another reason why men are doing better
in chess than women because we know
women go shopping you know they like to
you know have more friends and you know
do hair and makeup either but land need
or more serious and more focused on
chess so yeah those girls under the age
of 10 in my opinion I
than a statistical list but in my
opinion they can concentrate on even
better than danyoung boys but the
problem is that when they reach 12 or 13
girls seem to be completely distracted
they lose complete interest absolute
complete interest while boys change from
the silly little boys to complete
concentration on something a football
tennis chairs video games they become
boys when they become teenagers become
obsessive and girls tend to ever be
interested in other things and only in
1980s women started to play chess
professionally and seriously so women
play chess only thirty years
professionally and men have been play
chess many many years so it's just a
question of time and think first of all
because I don't see why women should be
weaker than men and chests of course men
will men have some places they will play
a little bit stronger but the difference
between women and men should not be so
big as we're seeing right now so it will
be changing it will change and I think
in ten years it will be many more women
grandmasters and the difference will
become smaller so it's just a question
of time
a bicycle computer
Darin k-prime Adela partita
multi-variant impersonated intimal topi
analytically variant a sono molto P
concrete see c'mon okay mondo catotti
coma soon Murray NT concrete in a modern
critical computer computer an acoustic
Apache technology to be choked Romania
tourists a tea cup in the un-led Munir
concrete oliveria a desi Java Nixon for
Mattie studi under computer acquisition
Costello's TV show Co in the aesthetic
amenties in video card elemental trunk a
loss token to Dlisted is oka too
energetic soon it piace demon of course
we will use computers but when we
analyze when we are on a camp or
somewhere with friends we we try to
minimize the level of computer
assistance just only final checkup with
computer just to see if tactical things
are not being out this ones have been to
Alan very aunty complicated coz I cannot
share control of premium today stupid
focus to control of property 10 chapter
very auntie ender Almaguer even chinko
Trentham awesome position complicate is
managed a local computer era Alaska
Kiera a java re' you need a decrepit
Razvi local Sudoku vintage FR cosas con
authenticity that is Aviv University
College alma a comp a logical Miguel
80% of my solo or quite poppy solo date
Illinois la cancion employee see
beginning adesso to Miami they're
fantastic enmity LaBelle bro
Jocasta saya saya Lucas unsuitable right
now you look at positions people they
play and people play positions which no
one would play before because chance
just becomes very defensive and you grab
the phone and you see them wait for 20
moves so before just was much less
materialistic in a way so yeah and
people learn to defend with computers
you can also working with computers of
course everybody's working with
computers it's easy it just gives the
position you ask and complete only test
like this in some instances you don't
feel you're just getting to later to
analyze by yourself with the finest
things of second but I can tell you in
the second signal as normal because this
new generation is used to work with
computers so it's much easier and
they're much faster than if you analyze
very deeply yami-chan was flow the only
job on the evaluation of adulteration
italian demands because okay I think
official official UN rato random extra
premature SM Bravo una causa
in fact India Genji factor down Jo
EPV match adesso particle they only said
if I miss a similar her pokemon a
frecuencia DVS : to tomando alameda she
Italian salami and on okay so I know
which was that in Korea so Gracia love
you computer program which is all a
silly joke okay dear fellow
chess it's like in our language between
two people it's a battle between two
people two intellectuals so I like chess
because very much because you know you
have 64 squares you have pieces on the
board and you can proof anything you
want to prove and it doesn't matter who
is in front of you you just play do your
best and you're a winner or a loser and
it depends on you totally on you chess
player had to have a fighting spirit
this is he can know all the theory in
the world he can be a machine
calculating I don't know but if if you
if it if a player gets a bad position
and he's not a fighter if you will lose
easily so I think one very important
element is never to give up in a game
used to cry all the time for two years
with money every month I'll pay you and
you can just play chess without worrying
about the financial point but on the
other hand I would have maybe done
nevertheless even without some money
punches to see how it is because it's a
good experience to go to Sally because
sometimes you have to go on your limits
you know like physically and
psychologically is sometimes common
situations where you don't know yourself
you just learn about yourself much
better than you are and indexfinger to
issues like you say are way like
sometimes evoke
was up at three o'clock and we had to
close the fourth at 3:00 in the morning
it was just tyrita
didn't shower and everything to just try
to to I don't want to say [ __ ] you here
but that's what I was trying to his
channel when we get up and it just
beside you know so matter like to feel
how strong are you as a person well I
remember when I was playing in in this
category tournaments we have it in South
Union you see you have to fulfil this
category dedicated going just to play
with other guys and I was playing second
category tournament and one guy was
crushing me absolutely crushing me and
then that day he told me why don't you
resign and I almost died at that moment
this one I remember because I was full
of tears you see this this is the
childhood I remember and and what I
remember from the story on the next day
I was playing with the guy I took all
his pieces almost everything and then at
one month he wants to castle he touches
his rope first and I told him no no no
if you touch your roof you're gonna play
your rope no way you're going to Castle
so I became like very strict saying that
moment so just is a violent game I
remember when I was a kid you know my
parents were very scared because at
night I would talk in my sleep and I
would say like II 496 you know Castle my
parents were like hmm you know maybe
it's not for her maybe it's time to quit
you know they were scared but you know I
think it's normal because you think so
much about the game you play so long you
know your brain still working you know
so and you also it's a lot of stress to
play chess so sometimes when I go to
sleep I see some variations some
positions you know so no motive arrow
potential meant S&P particular CD ultra
cozy no / kpop you mentally know charlie
corporal meant equesticle pero su
Stettin vent at a university sarah for
cement okay Davis respond so playin Cora
knows okay okay
Qwest Republic a disposition is kaki
came a Victorian on corn on control on
Cholas config a Chilean özkan Fichte
Multipla grande delle Alpi shake
Ricardian car a Dorito CA Dora / - T's
khaki super Dobin osprey con la posición
Minto a laura-leigh demente a voltage
peasant Renault Tank Engine modo porches
insert a suppressor continue on Aikido
for knee chest very hot Kenny came in
when ago so time UN venom echoes - vamos
a cannon Uzi km/h is like a No yo a
tragic Sonia Van Leeuwen Mona penita and
chanmi diffuse I go Leo just fo x value
I KN Atlantic's potentia says just raita
kwon do you conscious has a perfect
position on de novo no Famer seunga's
esta vez de escena Pontius Estanza tar
sands oil tempo importante in vechicle
movie star coab estancia una volta fact
a photocopier a phony scotch in toto
Brasileiro visi probita sorry
the role of a party Villa de la Tita a
purpose in selecting their children to
prepare food it's very hard you know
like when you win you know you
especially if you win very important
match you know you just feel so happy
you know you
I don't probably be happiest to you have
ever felt you know I remember a lot of
Chester say when they win big tour and
they say oh this is happiest day of my
life you know you know sometimes people
say they when they get married you know
it's my happiest day or when they have a
baby but the chess players when they win
you know it's my happiest day so you
just feel very happy you know and you
feel smart and you feel proud of
yourself you know that's a very good
feeling like sometimes you're on the
winning streak then suddenly you make
some mistakes and you don't win anymore
of course the feeling is much clearer
because you saw you you couldn't one you
know because some chess it's much more
cool because the result is not so clear
from the beginning because everything
can change in the last moment Nexus
that's a problem basically so as the
mood I think in this very much much more
dependent like NASA sport it's much more
sensitive game and also other things I
say
now when you lose on the other hand you
know it's very hard I know a lot of
chess players cry and it's normal you
know for a chess player you know I
remember once when I was a kid you know
I am lost very important game and I was
so upset you know I went out in the park
next to the Chess Club playing hole and
I started to cry you know the tears
coming down and I cry so hard and my
friends are behind me you know I did it
they don't want to come close because
you know they don't know what to say you
know and people are walking in the park
you know so they see me cry you know and
they go to my friends what happened did
someone die you know did her mother die
or father know what happened it her
boyfriend leave her
No then what happening if she was a
Chesky what
that's why she's crying they thought I
was crazy you know but you know you put
a lot of emotions in this game you know
like you try so hard you know for so
long and when you lose you know it's
very painful you know you can play six
hours really well you know you can be
winning and then in one move you can
lose you know I mean some people take
their losses easily their wins like
something big happen but it was always
with me that I was after I started to
win some tournaments it went like I
wasn't really feeling so sorry for
losing anymore and so happy for winning
I don't know it went a little bit
different so less emotions but what
really inspires me that all my family
and all friends of mine are really
really getting very emotional about my
wins and that's a good part of it me
people sometimes have good moments
sometimes bad moments but really great
athletes and chess players they know how
to go ahead after the defeats and so the
most important thing when you lost a
match lost the game played badly in a
tournament just analyze why did this
happen and just stand up and go ahead
work on yourself work on chess and be
stronger than all the defeats you had